I want you to actually good I'm not
trying to make you look like ya guys
Justin Bieber just did his wife Hailey's
makeup and he freaking killed it
Justin's coming for every makeup artist
coming for you on Monday's episode of
the Bieber's on watch the singer dolled
up his wifey I have no idea
how did you yes right of course with a
little hmm okay a lot of guidance from
Haley never done this alone and he gave
her the works foundation concealer
bronzer blush and eye shadow he took the
whole thing pretty seriously and it was
really just the cutest no you sure yeah
because I don't want to turn okay yeah
so Justin Slade up until that point
goodness and might have gotten just a
little bit cocky my mascara pretty
confident bro
[Laughter]
whose turn into an exercise you know an
eyelash curler
yeah just in kind of went rogue for a
minute but he got back on track and
blessed us with this musical treat
[Music]
honestly though nothing was more
relatable than this who else never knows
what to do with their hands just me okay
moving along I'm doing the lovebirds
revealed the final look separates
indenter boys and guys it wasn't bad
pretty good yeah it's not bad at all
that's your new calling
okay maybe don't quit your day job
Pheebs that's a wrap
Justin recently released his new track
with Ariana Grande
stuck with you
[Music]
and he recruited Hales to star in the
music video the two have been quarantine
at his home in Toronto
amid the corona virus pandemic and
they've been staying pretty busy tick
tocking like crazy and giving fans an
inside look at their life together it's
just really fun to just experience new
things
the couple's new Facebook watch series
comes after Justin's docu-series Justin
Bieber seasons which launched in January
chronicling the singer's life and making
of his latest album changes this one
over here Halley she just every time I
do something stupid she forgives me so
there's that
et sat down with the docu-series
director Michael D Ratner in February he
opened up about Justin's decision to
share his life with the world plus we
watched episode 5 together and he was
just staring at it and he's like this is
tough and he said there's power and
weakness and I thought when he said that
you know he said the very reasons why
it's sometimes uncomfortable for me to
watch that as the reasons I went out
there
[Music]